investigators say that this shooting
suspect actually had a long-standing
grudge against this newspaper
Jared Ramos he actually sued after the
newspaper reported accurately on his
guilty plea to charges of harassing a
woman when he went to that he went to
high school with his defamation case
against the newspaper was dismissed now
in an interview you'll see only on CBS
this morning
chip Reid actually spoke to the attorney
who represented the woman that Ramos
harassed chip good morning this story
dates back a while
oh it's been going on for a decade in
fact Brennan McCarthy tells us his
client was harassed and stalked by Jared
Ramos for years and she lived in fear
for nearly a decade he says she was so
afraid of him she moved out of the state
of Maryland and the harassment allegedly
did not stop with her he was as angry
and individual as I have ever seen
attorney Brennan McCarthy says Jared
Ramos tormented his client for years she
lost her job because she lost her job
because of this individual
he's malevolent he forwarded a letter to
her employer basically stating that she
was bipolar and a drunkard which is
ridiculous McCarthy says the harassment
and stalking began around 2009 after
they became friends on Facebook in 2011
she took him to court where he pleaded
guilty to criminal harassment and was
placed on 18 months probation five days
later the Capitol Gazette wrote a story
titled Jared wants to be your friend it
outlined Ramos alleged erratic behavior
including emails he allegedly sent
telling McCarthy's client go hang
yourself you're going to need a
restraining order now and you can't make
me stop mr. Ramos was obsessively angry
about this particular story
Ramos sued the paper for defamation in
2012 the case was dismissed in 2015 on
appeal according to court documents the
judge said there is nothing to prove
anything that was published was in fact
false
I for one received what I considered to
be a death threat Tom Marquardt was the
Capitol's executive editor at the time
of the article he said he went to police
about Ramos threat but was told nothing
could be done I
for my life I fear for my family's life
and I feared for my staff's life he
wanted to get revenge McCarthy said on
Thursday when he heard about the
shooting at the capital newspaper he
immediately thought of Ramos I knew who
did it he did it and you said it was
inevitable it was inevitable that he was
going to do something violent the only
question was who would he get first
McCarthy said he spoke to his client
after the shooting and she said she is
still scared for her life even though he
is behind bars it's chilling they're
willing to hear those details chip thank
you so much